so yeah people normal people you know
that just here's
normal people that want to own a home
and raise their family in a safe
community
and and retire with dignity and and have
a country that's safe and stable
and have give their children a chance at
a better life they're going to vote
against
people that are crazy and that want to
undermine all of that
and that's what's at stake in this
election because if we don't control the
united states senate
that is the agenda that's going to be
pushed and it doesn't matter
it doesn't even matter of the majority
of the democrats if you polled them and
gave them true serum we're not in favor
of it
because all the energy in that party all
the money in that party
all the people who get on the cover of
magazines in that party
are in favor of these radical things now
there's one more there's one more
element that was
especially true in florida and that is
in south florida in particular we have a
lot of people who came to this country
to get away from socialism and marxism
and so these people are thinking to
themselves you know
i got on a boat i left everything behind
i risked being eaten by a shark
to get away from socialism why in the
world would i want to bring that now
here
and that's where and that's where
i'm reminded of senator loffler's
opponent
okay there's a true story the true story
he 25 years ago he was a pastor at a
church
in new york that invited fidel castro to
speak
and and i want you to go on c-span it's
there on the website and you'll find the
video it's there
they cheered him wildly that the speech
first he attacked america throughout the
speech there were people chanting we
wish we had you instead of mayor
giuliani and
then he ended the speech
fidel ended the speech by leading
a singing of the hymn you know which is
the hymn of global
socialism international or something i
don't know the words to it
think about that now you know 25 years
later the
one of the pastors the church wants to
be the u.s senator from
georgia
so i all that reminds me of is this
it is true to be fair not all democrats
are socialists
but all the socialists are democrats
[Applause]
bernie sanders to his credit he doesn't
lie about it he says i'm a socialist he
says it
and uh he caucuses with the democrats
and they're members of the house you may
know who they are
members of the socialist party but they
run as democrats they're in that part
and these aren't like fringe elements
they have real influence when they speak
people jump
what stands in the way of all that
becoming public policy in america
even half of it becoming public policy
in america
you through your vote in this race
and and i'll and let me just i'll close
with this
[Applause]
let me let me close you usually you get
to do these events and it's like this
one race
is the difference between that and what
we want for our country
here you have two of them this is
literally
you know the showdown of all showdowns
in terms of politics and what it means
and we don't want to win one of them we
want to win both of them we need to win
both
and and that is an extraordinary
opportunity
so if you're a local television station
and see they're represented here today
you're going to make a lot of money over
the next few weeks and
you know advertising so that's you're
going to have a lot of political
visitors
from all across the political spectrum
coming to speak
my understanding what i learned last
night is they're even inviting people to
move here because they can vote
i mean uh i uh
i gotta tell you i can't do that it
would create all kinds of problems for
me but but
um but but but that's how important this
is
that's how much this matters and all i'm
here to ask you to do is
is to tell you it's nothing i've said
here is an exaggeration as to what the
stakes are they're that important
and i know that we're going into
december and early january there's a lot
of other things that should be going on
in our lives this time of year
but this year is different what an
understatement this year's different but
this year's different and uh and it
matters
as much as any election i've ever been
involved in
and you've been given this unique
opportunity to make a difference and so
let there you know if you can knock on
that one extra door if you can bring
that one extra volunteer
if you can bring to the polls that one
extra worker that happens to have lived
here for more than
a couple hours if you can uh
anything you can do to be helpful we
just ask you to do it for the sake of
the entire country
this this is george's decision to make
but it's america that will live with the
consequences of the decision that they
make here
and so
[Applause]
we're going to do everything we can to
help
from across the border in florida
there's no wall and uh so
but uh and we're not gonna pay for it in
florida in case you're wondering but
but um but we're but we we um
we're gonna do everything we can to help
but ultimately the decision is in your
hands
and we just implore you as fellow
americans
do everything you can to win these races
we must win these races
i can't exaggerate what's at stake and
and i think uh
we couldn't and you couldn't have better
candidates this isn't even one of those
races where you're like well i don't
like the person but i'm going to vote
for him because i really just like the
other person these are good candidates
you should be proud of them
they they're great senators
they're patriots they share our values
they represent you well and one of them
who you're here from now is is i think a
rising star in our party and
and really someone who i think is going
to be a critical
key player and so much of what our
party's going to be able to do for our
country in the years to come
and that's why i want to bring on now
the person you're really here to hear
speak and that is senator kelly lawful
she's going to win
thank you
thank you wow you guys are awesome
you guys are awesome thank you so much
wow
let me say happy veterans day georgia
my goodness yes we we love our veterans
and i love y'all
thank you so much for getting us here we
have been through a battle but we are
not done yet look at the work we have to
do that marco just talked about and it's
just the tip of the iceberg
you know and i want to thank congressman
collins for his support for his
endorsement because we as a party
that's right that's right that's right
we are going to lock arms and deliver
this country we are going to deliver the
american dream the road to socialism
does not run through georgia
[Applause]
so you may have heard
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you